national security reporter Greg Miller
co-authored The Washington Post story
good morning good morning
so last night a number of White House
officials called the story false this
morning President Trump said he had the
absolute right to share these terrorism
facts what's your take yeah so once
again we're seeing the president sending
out his team his subordinates
to advance one story line and then he
immediately comes behind them and pulls
the rug right out from under them I
interpret his tweets this morning as
essentially confirming what we reported
yesterday and trying to offer some sort
of defense that he did so for legitimate
reasons I think that that's hard to
square with how this conversation was
characterized to us in our story in
which he was essentially boasting to
these Russian officials about his inside
knowledge of a very sensitive Islamic
state threat I wonder why they're
constantly defending the notion that
there were no disclosure of sources and
methods in fact that was never something
you alleged that's right our story was
actually included a sentence that said
that Trump did not disclose the specific
collection mechanism here or capability
nor did he identify the ally that
provided it but he went into significant
detail on the intelligence that came
through that intelligence Channel and
that was what was problematic because
Russia which has highly capable
intelligence services of its own could
possibly reverse-engineer that
information and figure out where it had
come from
so Greg won White House official who was
in the room during this meeting says
that the sources that you're quoting
were people who either weren't there or
no longer in the government so how do
you determine how you can rely on the
sources that you get I think everybody's
curious about how you got the story I'm
not asking about your sources but did
you get a call did you get an email what
happened I mean I don't want to go into
really any detail about our sourcing on
the story except to say that we had
multiple sources multiple sources
corroborating this information and that
it is all held up and that other news
organizations have since matched the
story Trump's tweets today basically
confirm the store
and we had lengthy lengthy interactions
with the White House all day yesterday I
had two separate conversations with the
National Security Advisor HR McMaster in
which he never said which we discussed
the details at length he never said it
was false until after it was published
all right so how so have we heard yet
from the country that was supposed was
classic was sending this information and
who the relationship may have been at
risk because it was disclosed do we know
what their reaction has been you know we
didn't identify that country in the
store and asked me to identify it I may
be right important but didn't but we've
said in the story I don't know that
we've seen yet a reaction but we know
what we do know that this is a country
that in the past has expressed deep
concern about the United States
inability to safeguard secrets that this
country provides so I think it's safe to
expect that they're not going to be very
happy with this latest disclosure well
Mike Morell said in a in a previous
conversation earlier today that HR
McMaster should have informed the
president about the sensitivity of this
to stop talking right while in the White
House well I think it would have been
might have been difficult you know I
think it speaks to the to the sort of
atmosphere in this White House that note
that nobody it appears is in position to
challenge Trump on these kinds of issues
in fact one of the details in our story
talks about the lengths that the his own
national security staff goes to to try
to prepare him for meetings like this
they put together you know two to five
page briefing papers that he's expected
to read to understand how to handle a
meeting with foreign leaders and he
insists that those all be boiled down to
single page bullet points and he often
just sets those aside Greg you really
take us inside that oval office meeting
as you describe that White House
officials immediately recognize that the
president may have quote overstepped is
what you write and that the CIA and NSA
were called immediately to begin a
discussion about this what did you learn
about that what were they concerned
about well they were concerned about the
fallout and I think this is something
else that really undercuts those denials
we saw from the White House
last night if this was all appropriate
and there was no problem here why was it
that White House officials were quickly
calling the CIA director and the NSA
director to give them a heads-up on what
had just happened and the purpose of
those calls was to warn them because
those agencies are the ones that deal
directly with this partner they're the
ones that are going to have to deal
directly with any fallout Greg Mello
thank you great reporting